[Music]
the art of war then is governed by
five constant factors to be taken into
account in one's deliberations
when seeking to determine the conditions
obtaining
in the field
[Music]
these are the way heaven
earth the commander method
and discipline therefore in your
deliberations when seeking to determine
the military conditions
let them be made the basis of a
comparison
in this way which of the two sovereigns
is imbued with the moral law
which of the two generals has the most
ability
with whom lie the advantages derived
from heaven
and earth on which side is discipline
most rigorously enforced which army is
stronger
on which side are officers and men more
highly trained
in which army is there the greater
constancy both in reward and punishment
by means of these seven considerations i
can forecast
victory or defeat all
warfare is based on deception
hence when able to attack we must seem
unable
when using our forces we must seem
inactive when we are near
we must make the enemy believe we are
far away
when far away we must make him believe
we are near
if your opponent is of a choleric temper
seek to irritate him pretend to be weak
that he may grow arrogant if he is
taking his ease
give him no rest if his forces are
united
separate them attack him where he is
unprepared
appear where you are not expected
[Music]
the skillful soldier does not raise a
second levy
neither are his supply wagons loaded
more than twice
bring war material with you from home
but forage
on the enemy thus the army will have
food enough for its needs
poverty of the state exchequer causes an
army to be maintained by contributions
from a distance contributing to
maintaining an army at a distance causes
the people
to be impoverished now in order to kill
an enemy
our men must be roused to anger that
there may be advantage from defeating
the enemy
they must have their rewards therefore
in chariot fighting when 10 or more
chariots have been taken
those should be rewarded who took the
first
our own flags should be substituted for
those of the enemy
and the chariots mingled and used in
conjunction with ours
the captured soldiers should be kindly
treated
and kept thus it may be known that the
leader of
armies is the arbiter of the people's
fate
the man on whom it depends whether the
nation shall be in peace
or in peril
sun tzu said in the practical art of war
the best thing of all is to take the
enemy's country whole
and intact to shatter and destroy it
is not so good
[Music]
so too it is better to recapture an army
entire
than to destroy it to capture a regiment
or detachment or a company entire
than to destroy them hence to fight and
conquer in
all your battles is not supreme
excellence
supreme excellence consists in breaking
the enemy's resistance
without fighting thus the highest form
of generalship
is to bulk the enemy's plans
the next best is to prevent the junction
of the enemy's forces
the next in order is to attack the
enemy's army in the field
and the worst policy of all is to
besiege
walled cities
it is the role in war if our forces
attend to the enemies one
to surround him if five to one to attack
him
if twice is numerous to divide our army
into two
if equally matched we can offer battle
if
slightly inferior in numbers we can
avoid the enemy
if quite unequal in every way we can
flee from him
hence though an obstinate fight may be
made by a small force
in the end it must be captured by the
larger force
thus we may know that there are five
essentials for victory
he will win who knows when to fight and
when
not to fight he will win who knows how
to handle both superior
and inferior forces he will win
whose army is animated by the same
spirit
throughout all its ranks he will win
who prepared himself waits to take the
enemy
unprepared he will win who has military
capacity
and is not interfered with by the
sovereign
the skillful fighter puts himself into a
position which makes defeat
impossible and does not miss the moment
for defeating the enemy
thus it is that in war the victorious
strategist
only seeks battle after the victory has
been
won whereas he who is destined to defeat
first fights and afterwards looks for
victory
the consumer leader cultivates the moral
law
and strictly adheres to method and
discipline thus
it is in his power to control success
in respect of military method we have
firstly
measurement secondly estimation of
quantity
thirdly calculation fourthly
balancing of chances fifthly
victory measurement owes its existence
to earth
estimation of quantity to measurement
calculation to estimation of quantity
balancing of chances to calculation and
victory
to balancing of chances
a victorious army as opposed to a routed
one is as
a pound's weight placed in the scale
against a single grain the onrush of a
conquering force
is like the bursting of a pent-up waters
into a chasm
of a thousand fathoms deep
[Music]
fighting with a large army under your
command is no wise different from
fighting with a small one
it is merely a question of instituting
signs
and signals in all fighting
the direct method may be used for
joining battle but
indirect methods will be needed in order
to secure victory
indirect tactics efficiently applied
are inexhaustible as heaven and earth
unending as the flow of rivers and
streams like the sun
and the moon they end but to begin anew
like the four seasons they pass away
to return once more
there are not more than five musical
notes
yet the combination of these five give
rise to more melodies that can ever be
heard
there are not more than five primary
colors blue yellow red white and black
yet in combination they produce more
hues that can ever be
seen there are not more than five
cardinal tastes
sour acrid salt sweet bitter
yet combinations of them yield more
flavors than can be ever tasted
in battle there are not more than two
methods of attack
the direct and the indirect yet these
two in combination
give rise to an endless series of
maneuvers
the quality of decision is like the
well-timed swoop of a falcon
which enables it to strike and destroy
its victim
therefore the good fighter will be
terrible in his onset
and prompt in his decision energy may be
likened to the bending of a crossbow
decision to the releasing of the trigger
simulated disorder postulates perfect
discipline
simulated fear postulates courage
simulated weakness
postulates strength hiding order beneath
the cloak of disorder
is simply a question of subdivision
concealing courage under a show of
timidity presupposes
a fund of latent energy masking
strength with weakness is to be affected
by
tactical dispositions thus one who is
skillful at keeping the enemy on the
move maintains
deceitful appearances according to which
the enemy will act
he sacrifices something that the enemy
may snatch at it
the clever combatant looks to the effect
of combined energy and does not require
too much from individuals
hence his ability to pick out the right
men and utilize
combined energy when he utilizes
combined
energy his fighting men become as it
were
like unto rolling logs or stones
for it is the nature of a log or stone
to remain motionless
on level ground and to move when on a
slope
if four cornered to come to a standstill
but if round shaped
to go rolling down thus the energy
developed by good fighting men
is as the momentum of a round stone
rolling down a mountain
thousands of feet in height so much
on the subject of energy
[Music]
whoever is first in the field and awaits
the coming of the enemy
will be fresh for the fight whoever is
second in the field and has to
hasten to battle will arrive exhausted
therefore the clever combatant imposes
his will on the enemy
but does not allow the enemy's will to
be imposed on him
he can cause the enemy to approach of
his own accord or
by inflicting damage he can make it
impossible for the enemy
to draw near
you can be sure of succeeding in your
attacks
if you only attack places which are
undefended
you can ensure the safety of your
defense if you only hold positions that
cannot be attacked
hence that general is skillful in attack
whose opponent does not know
what to defend and he is skillful in
defense whose opponent does not know
what to attack oh divine art of subtlety
and secrecy through you we learn to be
invisible
through you inaudible and hence we can
hold
the enemy's fate in our hands
the spot where we intend to fight must
not be made known for then the enemy
will have to prepare against a possible
attack
at several different points and his
forces being thus
distributed in many directions the
numbers we shall have to face at any
given point
will be proportionately few
having collected an army and
concentrated his forces
he must blend and harmonize the
different elements thereof before
pitching his camp after that comes
tactical maneuvering
than which there is nothing more
difficult the difficulty of tactical
maneuvering
consists in turning the devious into the
direct
and misfortune into gain
thus to take a long and circuitous route
after enticing the enemy out of the way
and
though starting after him to contrive to
reach the goal before him
shows knowledge of the artifice of
deviation
maneuvering with an army is advantageous
with an undisciplined multitude
most dangerous let your rapidity be that
of the wind
your compactness that of the forest in
raiding and plundering be like
fire in immovability like a mountain
let your plans be dark and impenetrable
as night
and when you move fall like a
thunderbolt
it is a military axiom not to advance
uphill against the enemy
nor to oppose him when he comes downhill
do not pursue an enemy who simulates
flight do not attack
soldiers whose temper is keen do not
swallow
bait offered by the enemy do not
interfere with an army that is returning
home when you surround an army
leave an outlet free do not press
a desperate foe too hard
such is the art of warfare
[Music]
when in difficult country do not in camp
in country where high roads intersect
join hands with your allies
do not linger in dangerously isolated
positions
in hend in situations you must resort
to strategy in desperate positions you
must fight
there are roads which must not be
followed armies which must not be
attacked
towns which must be besieged positions
which
must not be contested commands of the
sovereign
which must not be obeyed
the general who thoroughly understands
the advantages to the company variation
of tactics
knows how to handle his troops
the general who does not understand
these may be well acquainted with the
configuration of the country
yet he will not be able to turn his
knowledge to practical
account
the art of war teaches us to rely not on
the likelihood of the enemy
not coming but on our own readiness to
receive him
not on the chance if he's not attacking
but rather on the fact that we have made
our position unassailable
[Music]
there are five dangerous faults which
may affect a general
recklessness which leads to destruction
cowardice which leads to capture a hasty
temper
which can be provoked by insults a
delicacy of honor which is sensitive to
shame
over solicitude for his men which
exposes him to worry and trouble
these are the five besetting sins of a
general
ruin us to the conduct of war
[Music]
after crossing a river you should get
far away from it
when an invading force crosses a river
in its onward march
do not advance to meet it in mid-stream
it will be best to let half the army get
across
and then deliver your attack if you are
anxious to fight
you should not go to meet the invader
near a river which he has to cross
when you come to a hill or a bank occupy
the sunny side
with the slope on your right rear thus
you will at once act for the benefits of
your soldiers and utilize the natural
advantages of the ground
when in consequence of heavy rains up
country
a river which you wish to afford is
swollen and flecked with foam
you must wait until it subsides country
in which there are precipitous cliffs
with torrents running between
deep natural hollows confined places
tangled thickets quagmires and crevasses
should be left with all possible speed
and
not approached
if his place of encampment is easy of
access
he is tendering abate movement amongst
the trees or forest
shows that the enemy is advancing the
appearance of a number of screens in the
midst of a
thick grass means that the enemy wants
to make us
suspicious the rising of birds in their
flight
is the sign of an ambush startled beasts
indicate that her sudden attack is
coming
[Music]
sun tzu says we may distinguish six
kinds of terrain accessible ground
entangling ground
temporizing ground narrow passes
precipitous heights
positions at a great distance from the
enemy ground which can be freely
traversed by both sides
is called accessible with regard to
ground of this nature
be before the enemy and occupying the
raised and sunny spots
and carefully guard your line of
supplies
then you will be able to fight with
advantage ground which can be abandoned
but is hard to reoccupy
is called entangling
regard your soldiers as your children
and they will follow you into the
deepest valleys
look upon them as your own beloved sons
and they will stand by you
even unto death if however you are
indulgent but unable to make your
authority
felt kind-hearted but unable to enforce
your commands and incapable moreover of
quelling disorder
then your soldiers must be likened to
spoiled
children they are useless for any
practical purpose
[Music]
those who were called skillful leaders
of old knew
how to drive a wedge between the enemies
front
and rear to prevent cooperation between
his large
and small divisions to hinder the good
troops
from rescuing the bad the officers from
rallying
their men throw your soldiers into
positions whence there is no escape
and they will prefer death to flight if
they will face death
there is nothing they may not achieve
officers and men alike will put forth
their uttermost
strength soldiers when in desperate
straits
lose the sense of fear if there is no
place of refuge
they will stand firm if they are in
hostile country
they will show a stubborn front if there
is no help for it
they will fight hard
the skillful tactician may be likened to
the shwai
jan now the schweijan is a snake that is
found in the chung mountains
strike at its head and you will be
attacked by its tail
strike at its tail and you will be
attacked by its head strike at its
middle
and you will be attacked by head and
tail
both
[Music]
sun tzu said there are five ways of
attacking with
fire the first is to burn soldiers in
their camp
the second is to burn stores the third
is to burn
baggage trains the fourth is to burn
arsenals and magazines the fifth
is to hurl dropping fire amongst the
enemy
in order to carry out an attack we must
have
means available the material for raising
fire
should always be kept in readiness
there is a proper season for making
attacks with fire and special days for
starting a conflagration
the proper season is when the weather is
very dry the special days are
those when the moon is in the
constellations of the sieve
the wall the wing or the crossbar
for these four days are all days of
rising wind
in attacking with fire one should be
prepared to meet
five possible developments when fire
breaks out inside an enemy's camp
respond at once with an attack from
without
if there is an outbreak of fire but the
enemy's soldiers remain quiet
abide your time and do not attack when
the force of the flames has reached its
height
follow it up with an attack if that is
practicable
if not stay where you are if it is
possible to make an assault with fire
from without
do not wait for it to break out within
but deliver your attack
at a favorable moment when you start a
fire
be windward of it do not attack
from the leeward
[Music]
raising a host of a hundred thousand men
and marching them great distances
entails heavy losses on the people and a
drain on the resources
of the state the daily expenditure will
amount to a thousand ounces of silver
there will be commotion at home and
abroad and men will drop down exhausted
on the highways
as many as 700 000 families will be
impeded in their labor
hostile armies may face each other for
years
striving for the victory which is
decided in a single day
this being so to remain in ignorance of
the enemy's condition simply because one
grudges the outlay of 100 ounces of
silver
is the height of inhumanity one who acts
thus
is no leader of men no present help to
his sovereign no master of victory
thus what enables the wise sulfrin and
the good
general to strike and conquer and
achieve things beyond the reach of
ordinary men
is for knowledge
now this foreknowledge cannot be
elicited from spirits
it cannot be obtained inductively from
experience nor by any deductive
calculation
knowledge of the enemy's dispositions
can only be obtained
from other men hence the use of spies
of whom there are five classes local
spies
inward spies converted spies
doomed spies and surviving
spies when these five kinds of spy are
all at work
none can discover the secret system
this is called divine manipulation of
the threats
it is the sovereign's most precious
faculty
having local spies means employing the
services of the inhabitants of a
district
having inward spies making use of
officials of the enemy
having converted spies getting hold of
the enemy's spies
and using them for our own purposes
having doomed spies doing certain things
openly for purposes of deception
and allowing our spies to know of them
and report them to the enemy
surviving spies finally are those who
bring back
news from the enemy camp hence it is
that which
none in the whole army are more intimate
relations
to be maintained than with spies
none should be more liberally rewarded
in no other business should greater
secrecy be
preserved spies cannot be usefully
employed
without a certain intuitive sagacity
hence it is only the enlightened ruler
and the wise general who will use the
highest intelligence of the army
for purposes of spying and thereby
they achieve great results
i hope you've enjoyed the selection of
extracts from the art of war by sun tzu
if you'd like to study these teachings
in more depth i'd like to recommend the
ultimate
art of war a step-by-step illustrated
guide to sun tzu's teachings
by anthony cummins
bye